[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui bernard alghisi sa mort cette
semaine je me permets le temps
magnifique elle pour pouvoir aller à
l'extérieur profit de la nature est
justement un vous rappeler qu'on a des
responsabilités face à cette nature qui
présentement nous permet quand même hein
le genre de tampon l'évacuation de tout
le stress qui est accumulé à cause
justement de la pandémie mais surtout à
cause des restrictions c'est qu'on peut
pas se voit rester à l'extérieur pour le
mât pour beaucoup de gens et c'est venu
vraiment faire sonner quelque chose
parce que j'ai lu un article justement
cette semaine mais c'est pas là parfois
j'en entends parler c'est pas la
première fois la dernière fois que j'ai
entendu parler non plus c'est en lien
avec couloir énergétique qui tenteraient
de se négocie ce retraité numéro 8 dans
les territoires de l'alberta luz que
j'ai eu la chance et la malchance en
même temps de pouvoir aller me promener
pendant la marche la guérison pour
parler des effets dévastateurs des
sables bitumineux est pourquoi je vais
en parler c'est pas uniquement pour
parler de sa victime il est aujourd'hui
c'est pas pour parler des chefs qui
s'arrangent entre eux pour pour faire un
couloir énergétique qui va pas passer du
pétrole ou la foresterie des mines et
ray ce sont des choses qui se développe
quand même dans beaucoup de coins du
canada dans beaucoup de pauses devenue
lucy walker certains membres de la
communauté trouve vraiment avantageux de
pouvoir exploiter les ressources sur
leur propre territoire et développer une
économie d'ailleurs souvent quand on
voit au sein même des communautés et les
tensions qui existent à cause justement
du débat sur devrait-on faire
l'exploitation des ressources sur mon
territoire ou pas souvent il ya les
argumentaires comme c'est un projet
intelligence et d'avenir
comment est-ce qu'on tombe
pouvoir payer des choses dans notre
communauté si on ne fait pas ce genre
d'économie d'eau avec ce chrono sur
notre territoire
il s'oppose souvent aussi a dit que des
gens de la communauté des noms des
communes et conseil traditionnel on a pu
le voir certains conseils traditionnels
comme les web souhaitant par exemple en
2020 qui paie en opposition avec
certaines des décisions les confins de
vendre des chefs
c'est un exemple que je voulais apporter
parce que c'est pas uniquement sur les
questions environnementales dont on va
voir l'opposition entre les chefs et des
membres des communautés humaines et
membre de la communauté des membres de
la communauté et même des chefs condé
chef
pourquoi je vais un essai de la vente
c'est qu'il ya quand même une grande
problématique au sein de nos communautés
de notre milieu et de notre milieu aussi
que les construit avec la loi sur les
indiens avec les conseils des métis avec
les structures coloniales qui font
partie de notre quotidien c'est que on
entend très peu la voix de ceux qui ne
sont pas dans ce système là ça commence
je dire il ya quelques années on
n'entendait plus parler
les chefs et les luttes et les chefs
amené l'avant et défendre au nom de la
communauté mais de plus en plus on
attend aussi les organismes leçon
d'amitié
il a une des grandes problématiques qui
existe et que je vois ressortir
justement depuis des années c'est ceux
qui ont des formes de pouvoir sur ce
qu'ils essaient d'avoir une plateforme
pour faire entendre leurs voix leurs
messages ou mêmes leur détresse
c'est que pour beaucoup on veut pas
mettre sur la place publique
notre linge sale pourquoi parce qu'après
science et instrumentalisé par des gens
qui ne sont pas des communautés
autochtones pour pouvoir dire à regarder
ils sont comme ça ou alors vous voyez
ils veulent avoir des projets
énergétiques et ça amène comme deux
trois niveaux de plus de pression
sociale sont des discussions devraient
avoir lieu au sein de nos communautés et
qui ne devrait pas être privés par des
formes de pouvoir et ce qui risque aussi
une généralisation des autochtones
généralisation des chefs de
généralisation et les organismes et
plutôt que de l'étudier de l'analyse et
de la même façon qu'au québec au canada
sur cheikh organise chaque politicien
chaque étudiant en généralistes sur le
groupe autochtone et là c'est allé
s'entendent même pas un truc de toute
façon et ça c'est extrêmement ce que je
veux amener avec ma chronique
aujourd'hui c'est premièrement vraiment
commencer à regarder vers l'avenir vers
ces discussions disent ils vont avoir
lieu entre dr sur des enjeux qui l'ont
touché uniquement les communautés
autochtones parce que ont découlé de la
des droits se trouvent ou des droits
liés à la loi sur les héritiers il va
falloir qu'on puisse protéger s'excuser
d'avoir lu parce que sinon on risque de
faire taire les membres des communautés
qui veulent par exemple dans le cas de
des numéros vite puisque j'avais été sur
les le site justement des sables
bitumineux
on entendait des membres des communautés
qui devait regarder ces prochains nous
empoisonnent nous rendent malades
prennent aux territoires et c'était
souvent opposés avec ceux qui voulaient
avoir les projets ce qui suit nous on
négocie on s'est entendus on a des
ententes préalable avec les compagnies
et donc certaines voix sur plus forts
cadeau et vous pouvez imaginer que dans
des milieux hadôken une voix fort ça
veut pas dire une voix forte
la discussion qu'elle donc si en même
temps on arrive au niveau politique
canadien le savez de même une autre
bataille pour avoir le crachoir pour
pouvoir disputer pour quoi faire
entendre une voix quand le gouvernement
ou les fonds de gouvernance ont toujours
été habitués à traiter avec une seule
forme de devoir de discussion donc sauf
ouvrir nos yeux vers l'avenir faut
pouvoir aussi permettre à la voix des
personnes qui n'ont pas souvent la
parole à paroles qui n'ont pas les
médias j'espère en attente d'une façon
qui va les protéger qui va leur
permettre justement
libérer la parole donc n'hésitez pas à
écouter les gens sur le terrain et ce
n'est pas non plus à protéger les
discussions qui peuvent se passer de se
produire dans les communautés
autochtones parce qu'elles sont fragiles
elles sont vulnérables face à des formes
de discrimination systémique et elles
vont souvent même perpétuer les formes
d'oppression au sein même des
communautés
je vous dis juste tourner votre arrivée
vers les communautés vers les personnes
à risque et de vous informer sur ces
sujets la chouette une belle semaine il
se doit partager notre chronique
il n'est pas non plus allé voir sur les
différentes plateformes la version du
podcast alors cette baisse est même